[Music]
powerful earthquake shook Morocco
killing more than a thousand people
destroying buildings and setting off a
scramble to rescue those trapped under
the debris
the magnitude 6.8 Quake struck less than
50 miles from the ancient city of
Marrakesh a popular tourist destination
the room started shaking there's no
other way we was going backwards and
forwards and everything started moving
and pictures started moving and so we've
every we just grabbed uh grabbed some
clothes and our bags and we raised that
along with the collapsed buildings a
historic mosque was damaged but
Marrakesh escaped the worst of it
rural areas that are difficult to access
suffered the most severe damage
officials said Tremors were felt across
the country and as far away as Portugal
officials said the timing of the Quake
which hit at 11 11 pm when most people
were home also made things worse videos
showed residents and tourists clearing
restaurants and spilling out onto the
streets shortly after the Quake
[Music]
efforts to rescue residents trapped
under the debris are underway with many
more injured and in critical condition
authorities said they expected the death
toll to rise
according to the U.S Geological Survey
earthquakes in Morocco are uncommon but
not unexpected however there has been
none of this size within about 310 miles
of Friday's quake since 1900.